President Trump is lashing out at the  powerful conservative activists and  donors Charles and David Koch in a tweet  this morning the president called the  brothers a quote total joke in real  Republican circles he said I don't need  their money or bad ideas the president  went on to call their network quote  highly overrated over the weekend about  500 coke donors gathered for a seminar  Charles Koch who leads their political  organizations slammed mr. Trump's trade  policies and said they could trigger a  recession Koch reportedly also said he  would back Democrats if they aligned  with his values Koch officials have said  they plan to spend between 300 and 400  million dollars on the upcoming midterm  elections